agent curran was your typical scp
foundation field worker while sometimes
she spent her days infiltrating the
hideouts of dangerous groups of
interests such as the chaos insurgency
or the serpent's hand or protecting a
small town from a monstrous anomaly set
on devouring each and every inhabitant
the vast majority of her work was
routine and with that mundane workload
came boredom filing papers filling out
reports and running to get her
supervisor's coffee was just as much a
part of her job as keeping the anomaly
secured contained and protected from the
outside world as a result agent curran
had a lot of time on her hands and one
way she enjoyed filling it was with a
good book she loved to read sometimes
even more than she loved her real job
sometimes she thought about taking a
position observing the wanderers library
where she could have a multiversal
bibliography to pour over and more free
time than she'd know what to do with it
makes sense if you had to face dangers
as frequently as an agent of the scp
foundation does which is usually on a
weekly basis then you'd want an escape
from real life too for agent curran
that's what reading was and she liked
being able to say she actually read all
those literary classics that people
pretend to have read to sound smart one
aspect of agent curran's job was
inspecting areas around the location she
was stationed at for potential anomalous
activity this included keeping up with
local news checking secondhand stores
for anomalous objects that might have
unknowingly gone up for sale or simply
hanging around town and waiting for
something interesting to happen most of
the time it didn't agent kern was
located in a medium-sized texas town
where the most exciting thing that
happened on any given day was a sale at
the local supermarket this left her with
a lot of reading time and thankfully the
town had a bookstore it was a secondhand
shop selling used books and old
newspapers for someone who'd read all
the mainstream staples of literature
this place was a treasure trove of
interesting finds books she'd never
heard of books she wasn't even sure were
printed on a high enough run there were
some truly valuable and rare finds in
this shop and agent kern made it a point
to visit the store whenever she had the
opportunity to the most difficult part
of her daily patrol was not spending all
of it inside the shop pouring over each
and every new and interesting book she
came across but one day she found
something new something that intertwined
her love of literature with her career
focus and containing the supernatural
she stumbled upon scp-423
while walking down the aisle of stuffed
bookshelves she found a copy of mark
twain's tom sawyer sitting on the floor
piled atop a stack of books and almost
inviting her to pick it up tom sawyer
was one of the first books she read on
her own as a kid and agent curran had a
fondness for the novel ever since she
picked the book up and thumbed through a
few pages out of habit not expecting to
see anything she hadn't and at first she
didn't but one single sentence caught
her eye in which tom was described as
talking to another child by the name of
fred now agent curran was a well-read
bibliophile and she knew twain's
masterpiece like the back of her hand
there was certainly no fred in tom
sawyer intrigued she read on the
following pages depicted an extended
conversation between tom sawyer and this
mysterious fred regarding the types of
snakes that live in the woods that
surround the quiet town of saint
petersburg missouri agent curran was
taken back completely was this a part of
the book she had forgotten about sensing
a potential oddity she decided to
purchase the book and compare it to the
various copies in her expansive personal
collection while she didn't find any new
books to read on her trip to the store
that day she did find something to
occupy her mind and for agent curran
that was enough to make the quiet days
pass when she returned back to the
foundation facility she was stationed at
located in sector 28 agent curran
immediately began cross-referencing the
copy of tom sawyer with other copies
that were available to her she rented
out as many as she could from the public
libraries in the area and even used the
foundation's printed works archive she
found as many printings as possible even
multiple of the same printing that the
copy she had bought from the bookstore
was supposedly from but when she began
her research she found that every copy
of tom sawyer was missing the
conversation about snakes there was no
characters by the name of fred in any of
the printing of the books she read the
entirety of the copy that she purchased
from the store and on top of the strange
conversation she also found several
other mentions of this fred character
who was apparently a boy that tom sawyer
went to school with fred was an
incredibly minor character but still
interacted with the other protagonists
on occasion and was even mentioned a few
times by tom and his other friend huck
while he wasn't present for someone with
as little of a role as fred the
characters sure seemed to pay him a lot
of attention though it was definitely
weird agent curran didn't find anything
particularly anomalous about the book at
least at first it could have been a
practical joke between people with a
very strange sense of humor or simply
the work of someone wanting to see if
they could get away with editing a copy
of a literary masterpiece and selling it
in hopes that some poor sucker would
discover it and set off a craze about a
misprinting whatever the answer was it
was decidedly ordinary and that didn't
sit well with agent curran she wanted
answers but she knew deep down that
getting them was going to be a tall
order but during her research she
discovered something that would earn the
object an scp classification one day
while sitting at her computer terminal
and pretending to work she was reading a
copy of herman melville's moby dick less
than a meter away sat this strange copy
of tom sawyer she had bought at the
bookstore a week earlier before her eyes
the words on the pages of moby dick
started to disappear
or alter themselves into new ones the
book felt heavier and agent curran swore
she felt new pages being added to it
when all the rapid alterations slowed
down she took another look at the pages
of moby dick hender john nearly dropped
to the floor in shock at what she was
reading the book now described a sailor
by the name of fred stationed on the
pequod the ship that was hunting the
giant sperm whale given the name moby
dick the book once again did not
describe fred as doing anything
particularly noteworthy he was in the
background of the story said some
dialogue to captain ahab about the
ship's upkeep and was mostly regulated
to standing around and watching even
during the scenes that described whaling
by now agent kern was positive the book
wasn't just a strange misprint it was an
anomalous object just as she originally
suspected she reported the fine to her
supervisors and a research team was
brought in shortly after to analyze the
book first the team observed the
anomaly's method of transmission which
was the placement of a character named
fred who took the form of an unimportant
minor character in the story between
book to book the anomaly was able to
move between narratives if they were
placed within a one meter radius of
another one for more than three minutes
like when it jumped from the copy of tom
sawyer to a copy of moby dick and later
when the research team initially tested
it to a copy of another book once the
anomalous effects were established the
anomaly was given the designation of
scp-423
nicknamed the self-inserting character
scp-423 as we just described does not
have a physical form it's the character
fred who is always an incredibly minor
character with an overall lack of
narrative importance fred is usually not
physically described in the story but
when he is he appears as an adult male
of average height and middle age but the
foundation quickly discovered that this
could change in narratives focusing
primarily around children such as tom
sawyer fred was a child in others that
featured non-human characters such as
george orwell's animal farm fred was an
animal whatever the story called for
scp-423 fit the constraints of the
narrative other characters when they
address or acknowledge scp-423
do not see its inclusion as odd or
unusual and the story proceeds as usual
with minor alterations to the text the
foundation discovered that scp-423 if
transferred to a journal has the
capability to communicate via writing
back and forth between a researcher and
the anomaly this allowed the foundation
to discern
scp-423's nature easier and figure out
how exactly the anomaly works but more
on that later from the foundation's
communications with scp-423
they found that it prefers fictional
narratives but testing proved that it
can enter itself into any written work
that features a narrative that means
biographies anecdotes and even the
foundation's very own research notes as
long as the prerequisite requirements
for a narrative are present such as
names events places and the bare
skeleton of a story
scp-423 can supplant itself into it the
process is also confined to physical
textual narratives purely visual or
electronic mediums such as television
shows video games and computers are all
off limits for scp-423
but testing has shown that scp-423 is
capable of entering graphic novels and
comic books though when the texts become
altered it will only affect dialogue and
text boxes paneling and art are unable
to be altered and will remain the same
but the textual elements around the
panels will change themselves to make
way for
scp-423's inclusion when scp-423 is
placed before a narrative it has
previously entered the effect will still
take place but this time the narrative
will become slightly altered once more
differing from the previous time as
cp-423 entered the narrative while this
is possible communication with scp-423
has shown that it much prefers to enter
narratives it has not previously seen as
testing with scp-423 is limited to
introducing it to new narratives the
foundation hasn't been able to answer a
lot of questions regarding scp-423's
capabilities does it eat does it sleep
what would happen if it died and can it
well the answers to these are unknown
scp-423 has shown it possesses a high
degree of narrative awareness and tends
to keep itself out of trouble or out of
situations that would result in death at
most scp-420 has been lightly injured in
some narratives but as soon as it enters
a new book the injuries it harbored in
the previous one seem to vanish entirely
as we mentioned before the foundation
can communicate with scp-423 through a
journal when scp-423 is introduced to
the journal which has questions written
inside beforehand to coax the entity in
after transmission has taken place as
cp-423's answers to those questions will
appear underneath once the entity is
introduced to a new narrative however
the answers will disappear entirely
meaning the foundation has to record
them before conducting any further
testing with scp-423
it is not believed that scp-423 is a
malicious entity as fred has been
incredibly cooperative with the
foundation answering questions and
hopping from narrative to narrative
during testing in her few attempts to
talk with the entity agent curran and
scp-423 got along well and spoke about
various books though curran was
instructed to not make any promises that
the foundation could introduce scp-423
to any book it wanted mainly scp-412
has focused its efforts on asking the
foundation for narrative with lots of
background characters specifically
because this makes it easier to blend in
and in fred's words watch the good stuff
largely the foundation has complied with
these requests under the condition that
if at any point scp-423 becomes
uncooperative it will be confined inside
the journal for an extended period of
time until it starts to listen again
while scp-423 isn't dangerous in and of
itself foundation personnel handling it
still have to keep an eye out if they're
taking written notes for whatever reason
within
scp-423's presence the entity can
transfer itself to them as a result all
research done regarding scp-423 must be
electronically recorded thankfully the
inclusion of a guest researcher fred in
any seasoned researcher's scp file is
going to raise some eyebrows so possible
scp-423 intrusions are easy enough to
detect
scp-423's containment procedures are
also similarly lacks keeping the anomaly
inside a plane marked journal with a
label 423 due to the anomaly's
relatively passive nature the foundation
has tested scp-423 with a plethora of
narratives just to see how it might
alter them and if those alterations
could garner any new information about
the anomaly let's take a look at some of
them
scp-423's experiments were authorized by
the overseer council and conducted by
the anomalies research head the esteemed
dr everett mann in all tests
scp-423 was introduced to an outside
narrative and after alterations took
place the text was read by foundation
personnel and recorded in the testing
log first up
scp-423 was introduced to tolkien's the
hobbit a fourth dwarf named freder was
present in gandalf's party of 13 on
their quest to reclaim the dwarves
mountain home from the dragon smog there
were small changes to the text such as a
lack of a lucky number being referenced
and the death of the character oin in
the final portion of the novel ferder
survives the journey dr mann had this to
say about the test
scp-423's role is larger in this work
allowing a better look at its effects
the dialogue written for the character
is similar to that written for the other
dwarves other differences in text match
tolkien's writing style as used in the
rest of the book another test introduced
scp-423 to jk rowling's harry potter and
the half-blood prince but too little
effect a wizard name fret appears but
very few changes in the actual story
were noted save for a scene in which
scp-423 is confused for an existing
character in the series fred weasley dr
mann noted
scp-423 displayed paranormal abilities
in the narrative though nothing out of
note for the fictional universe however
when returned to the journal
scp-423 said that it couldn't duplicate
them outside of that particular
narrative universe when scp-423 was
introduced to james joyce's rambling
incoherent masterpiece ulysses which is
composed of what might as well be
gibberish the entity immediately
returned to its journal where it wrote
out ow
bad idea dr mann noted
scp-423 dislikes the book and considers
it a potential punishment if he
misbehaves in the next text
scp-423 was introduced to a lyric sheet
for the classical piece battle hymn of
the republic written by julia ward howe
if you don't know it look it up after
this video because you've definitely
heard it before once inside scp-423
altered the lyrics i have seen him in
the watchfires of a hundred circling
camps and i can read his righteous
sentence by the dim and flaring lamps
were changed to fred has seen him in the
watchfires of a hundred circling camps
and fred can read his righteous sentence
by the dim and flaring lamps upon return
scp-420 stated that it found the
experience interesting but ultimately
did not want to do it again when
introduced to the nursery rhyme mary had
a little lamb it became freddy had a
little lamb a book of 365 haiku were
altered to include lines such as fred
watched silently or fred is also here
and only fred remains a phone book noted
no change and no reaction from scp-423
an aesop fable written on a metal
surface with magnetic plastic letters
saw new letters appear from the same
material and composition to include a
mention of scp-423
an english braille edition of homer's
odyssey noted no changes though scp-423
commented that the experience was more
boring than anything else when
introduced to a hard copy of the scp-423
experiment log no changes were noted
aside from fred being described as
ruggedly handsome in several sections
when researchers attempted to introduce
scp-423 to the qigramas episode a story
written by woody allen about a man who
was able to travel into fiction the
overseer council forbade the experiment
from proceeding unsure of what could
happen if two meta-aware characters made
contact with one another in another
scp-423 experiment the foundation gave
fred his very own story foundation
researcher torres wrote a small novella
appropriately titled fred's story
specifically to test scp-423's
capabilities as acting as a main
character fred's story was set in a
fantasy kingdom inhabited entirely by
beautiful women when the kingdom is
attacked the queen performs a ritual to
summon a hero from another dimension to
save them the hero is never given a name
but it is mentioned that he is male and
can transfer himself to different works
of fiction while
scp-423 was flattered that he had a
narrative all to himself he didn't
change much in the story the hero was
still unnamed and the text was largely
unaltered save for a single sentence
mentioning the queen's handmaiden
frederica after returning to the journal
423 had this to say i appreciate the
offer but i just can't i never deserve
to be in the spotlight now go check out
scp-1025 encyclopedia of common diseases
and scp-1230 a hero is born for more
anomalously literature-crazed scps